now if somebody for some reason what to
ever asked if you were subscribed to the
new old review I want you to think what
would have till do and then immediately
reply with yes I am and if that
statement happens to not be true then
you'll have to click that magicians red
button immediately which will also
result in regular Jojo content being
uploaded straight until YouTube feed
hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's Jojo Monday
which may or may not become a thing
don't actually hold me to that but in
any case it's time for me to ramble on
for I'd say just over 10 minutes
regarding a select topic which today is
one of those things that has annoyed me
most about the series which is the
narrative mishandling of Abdul which
includes the time-honored misuse of the
resurrection technique in storytelling
one of my favorites now if you're
familiar with my Stardust Crusaders
thoughts and you'll know that I do have
a fair bit of criticism regarding part
three but it's overwhelming strength is
that of its characters the Crusaders
themselves absolutely make this part and
almost all the heavy lifting is on them
and their interactions to make it
interesting and that's fine I guess
that's just what it is accept it and
you'll enjoy it doubt dole is of course
no exception I enjoy him every bit as
much as the rest of the gang and I do
very much appreciate that he is more of
a rock-solid second-in-command figure
he's someone that I found really
necessary at the outset of the series
because characters like Joseph and
polnareff they're well they're more in
the goofy side while the stoic serious
doer of Joe Toro and kakuhen are almost
exclusively those quiet serious firm so
after all inhabits the perfect middle
ground he can be fun and engaging barish
nana Gon's but he can also be incredibly
serious when the time calls for it which
it did rather early on in the grand
scheme of things when he and polnareff
had a falling-out and ultimately after
would be killed by the combination
attack from whole horse and Jay Galle
and this was a moment in Stardust
Crusaders that made me seriously
question the fabric of the series
because by this point I thought that we
were destined to go through a stand of
the week storyline with no changes
whatsoever to the status quo until the
very end when they eventually found dear
this moment through all of that into
turmoil and I really appreciated that
because for the first time in part 3 I
felt like I could not predict what was
going to happen and in addition to this
after was the perfect character to kill
because he was the balance of the group
an intermediary between every other
member and the only Crusader who I would
say was universally respected in terms
of Honor abilities and or whatever else
he can think of whatever it
dual Hallett which means that removing
him from the group is a fantastic
opportunity to force these other four
misfits to grow and evolve together to
make up for what aldo had left behind
and this is particularly evident in
polnareff who grew exponentially from
this experience taking responsibility
5dolls death avenging him and becoming a
far more mature being in general not
only that but this feeling of guilt
would also play porn RF in a future arc
featuring cameo in the hall hail to you
business and up until now I would say
that everything was actually going
rather well narrative Lee because I
loved Abdel and his death hurt a lot but
if anyone did have to be killed for the
sake of character growth of the others
then he was the prime candidate and it
worked
polnareff in particular was now a fully
fleshed out character and by that point
by far my favorite in the series and now
if we were to hit the pause button and
you were to ask me at this stage the
very simple question of what could have
ruined everything that was built up so
far I would have had one very clear
answer and that would be bringing after
back to life so of course that's exactly
what happened and to be clear I don't
mean literally I mean narrative Lee I've
no situation was of course explained as
such that he had never actually passed
on but the fact is that Archie did play
this event as a death regardless of how
it was reckoned that is what it was in
terms of storytelling and so his
reemergence into part three is a
resurrection device being invoked and
this is one of the things that I despise
most in all of fiction because
resurrection is almost always never used
well for every example I could give you
of successfully playing out a
character's death and then bringing them
back into the story I could find at
least 10 other examples of a time where
it was done very poorly and to the
detriment of the entire series and you
know I'll go to my beloved one piece as
a fantastic example of very very poor
resurrections yet your era is an
absolute fiend for abusing this device
to the point where one character took a
point-blank explosion intended to
destroy an entire city and just turned
up a couple of days later alive and well
well for a non anime example if I go
further back into my childhood I can
also record Buffy the Vampire Slayer
where at the end of one season season
five I believe Buffy sacrificed herself
to save the world she does only to be
literally resurrected at the beginning
of the next season and there are a
billion more examples because I'm sure
with old experiences device used on mass
in our lifetimes and you know what feel
free to state some of your own botched
resurrections in the comments below but
let's add this outdoor situation in
these two examples because what do all
three of these have in common well
firstly in each never case they
undermine the final action of the
character involved bail from one pays
Buffy and Abdul all acted heroically in
their final moments and it puts a big
dramatic full stop on to these events
they were powerful they were emotional
and the sense of loss was profound and
in general they were very very well done
pieces of storytelling
however these three moments would all be
retrospectively undermined by very
poorly handled decisions which was the
desire to bring these characters back
into the series now because I've
mentioned it I should say that the Buffy
example is the most understandable and
probably the most well done of the
selection I mean she was the main
character after all and there was a
grand sense of consequence for reviving
her which took an entire season to get
over it left a lasting damage I guess is
what I'm trying to say and that is one
of the better ways that you can handle
the resurrection without dolo there was
none of that it was complete 100 percent
lock our key decided to bring him back
one day and then found himself having to
reverse this wonderfully crafted death
and the very fact that I've delenn's up
being alive negates all of the emotion
we underwent during that scene and to be
perfectly frank it's kind of insulting
to the audience which I felt through pon
RF when he was so happy to have
afterlife as was I by the way he's a
great character but doing it in such a
haphazard way and having Joseph Totoro
and Calculon all just going yellow we
knew that all along bruh is pretty
rubbish and very much like a slap in the
face and here I should probably address
some talk on the internet that I've
stumbled upon regarding this situation
which is that Abdul was brought back
because of fan backlash well even then
Abdul was killed because Eric he
intended on having whole horse join the
Crusaders which is an interesting but
unsubstantiated idea other than this one
picture which in context makes all the
sense in the world because it appeared
during the arc when whole horse and the
Crusaders sort of incidentally I guess
accidentally teamed up to fight any on
other than that I've never been able to
find anything but pure fan speculation
on that idea now what we do have though
is a statement from Araki regarding
Abdul from vol 13 of the Joan iam which
is extremely enlightening and it goes a
little something like this I killed him
once in India because I'm always trying
to keep readers from getting bored with
the same pattern I also wanted to add
some reality to the story by having
someone get sacrificed
I thought it would be great to add in an
episode where they lose a team member I
didn't intend to erase him forever
though but I thought it would be too
easy if he came back to life immediately
so I want to prepare a flashy comeback
that readers would be able to accept
when I draw Jojo I never plan out the
small things in the end I managed to
bring our dough back just before they
reached Egypt but I never planned that
beforehand it was just an idea that came
to me while drawing now that I think
back on it since I killed him once they
probably should have made him more
important in the story of course these
thoughts all come to me after I've
already finished the story so I think
that makes things pretty unfortunately
clear Araki wanted to have the exact
effect that I did feel which was
breaking the pottery formula and adding
some nice unpredictability into the
series the thing that does kind of fade
out
shock me though is that arc he never
intended to leave after all dead
so everything that happened here was our
keys planning to some degree it wasn't
an accident or a sudden realization that
he had to work out go back into the
story no this was actually all
intentional and I think that's very
telling of our keys storytelling ability
in the early days of Jojo because in my
opinion this was completely botched and
our key would seem to concur with that
assessment and with that I do also need
to stress that this is not the end of
the outdoor problem the crappy
resurrection is look it's not great but
it is manageable if that resurrection
has a purpose like in the Buffy example
once again she was needed to helm the
series there is no Buffy the Vampire
Slayer without Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and she would be the key to a further
two seasons of that series but in
contrast Abdullah would go on to do well
nothing at all and nothing might be a
bit harsh because Abdullah in the second
half the series was still highly
enjoyable and he fit the ensemble very
well but it's so hard to think of any
reason other than liking the character
to have him incorporate it into this
story once again and Archie agrees with
this as well because he even admitted
that if he was going to do such thing
then at the very least Abdul should have
had some sort of pivotal role to play
because if you are going to compromise
your storytelling like that then it had
better be for a pretty damn good reason
and in that case that reason was
absolutely absent but for one final
candle on this outdoor cake
after having a powerful emotional death
and a joy-filled resurrection which you
know feel what you will about that but
after ultimate fate was simply to die
again and not just die again but
actually perish in one of the most
underwhelming ways possible at the hands
of Vanilla Ice and here is where I just
kind of lost it for the longest time I
actually
did not believe that Abdul was dead
because after everything we'd been
through with his character I was certain
that his ultimate purpose was not to
just vanish from existence leaving only
a pair of hands behind but here's what's
worse when it became clear that oh this
is actually serious
I mean Abdul is he's actually dead and
in response to that thought I felt
nothing at all and why was that well
because I've already experienced the
situation once and very recently as well
and in addition to that in a much more
well done death scene and actually made
me feel for both Abdul and polnareff but
by the time we reached out doles actual
death there was no emotion left to give
Araki had already played that card and
it was never going to be possible to
generate a similar reaction especially
with the abilities of Vanilla Ice I
cannot stress that enough in the first
I've told quite unquote death
it was a visceral depiction of him being
struck in the head and his seemingly
lifeless corpse was on display for his
allies and the audience to see it was
tangible and it was hard-hitting but
with vanilla ice that was the exact
opposite it was an instantaneous
vanishing from the world and other than
the words of the characters and some
hands there was no tangible evidence of
the death for the audience to latch onto
because yeah sure Abdul lost parts of
his arms the characters and jojo flausch
body parts before and had been perfectly
fine afterwards so for all intents and
purposes after all just vanished from
the story it almost feels as if Eric he
just decided to stop drawing him one day
and that was that and obviously that's
not what happened but this is the most
underwhelming ending possible to a
character that the author went so far
out of their way to resurrect so in the
end I can't help but think what was the
point of all of this if that's all there
was to after all then why not just leave
him dead or just don't kill them in the
first place save it for the encounter
with vanilla ice so that it can actually
have that intended permanent effect what
this displays to me is a distinct lack
of planning and narrative instinct that
will forever plague my overall
impression of Abdul a character who for
all intensive purposes should be nothing
but amazing and I really really did
enjoy his parts of the story both pre
and post resurrection but I don't think
that in the end these bits of fun were
worth the crazy mental gymnastics that
Archy had to engage in simply to bring
him back and obviously this is all a
very I guess a first of all problem
shall we say because whilst looking into
this I have found plenty of other people
who just don't care whatsoever about the
Nicolle and dramatic implications of
these events and to them I say you are
probably our keys perfect audience and I
am genuinely thrilled that you enjoyed
it for people like me though this
problem is like a haunting specter of a
part three of Georgia I just don't
understand how a professional
storyteller can get themselves into a
situation like this and it sounds an
awful lot to me like a kick-the-can
problem you know you'll deal with it
when you encounter it down the road
which never ever works out well but
either way it is what it is I've said my
piece and now I'm done so that pretty
much does it for this discussion on the
alto problem now what do you guys think
please do feel free to share your
thoughts in the comments below
won't you even join my disco it's over
and if you came from all Georgia content
then please to check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular Georgia Wanda much
of which is far more positive in this
video delivered straight tou tube feed
this has been the new old review and
I'll see you next time